what's up everybody it's your host
Travis on yeah I know I need a haircut
we g h down all right bet all right
what's up everybody it's your boy Travis
hun here with 12 talks you know we got
another Banger this time is not on T
Monday it's on Tuesday had practice
yesterday so I couldn't get it
done but yeah let's see what we got this
week hope everybody having a blessed
day and doing good right now got a
chance to take a break and reset this
weekend with my neighbors was out with
my
neighbors gotta break the just I didn't
go back home I met a couple neighbors
took them
fishing yeah
see see I took some of the neighbors
fishing man the first time ever fishing
they caught some fish I want to go see
them play the little football game since
I had time off
just been around in youth on my
break pretty much it chilling with some
friends and Leon
yeah it was out there hitting too got
some good neighbors they can play they
can
ball team was playing pretty good
too yeah they was just they was playing
they was they was going
crazy we was playing basketball the day
before so they he came doing the dance
was doing we play
basketball look like us and I got some
hoodies for y'all oh man that's
awesome yeah I get him some of my so
hoodies you know the I'm H hoodies cuz
they lose a game this season so yeah had
to drop off some swags to the neighbors
to their team make sure they just have
fun make sure they know I'm looking out
for them no matter what and to keep
supporting I'mma support
them but
yeah what coach prom was talking about
remind us what we got at State this
week
and to we got take one they don't we
going win so let's just take one and
we'll be right back where we need to be
let's flush that put it behind us we
didn't we we didn't do what we were
supposed to do now we got to do
exceedingly abundantly above all that
that they think we going to do we
understand that let's go take it nobody
ain't going to give it to us let's go
take it the only thing you got to do you
got to prepare you got to understand
your assignment your alignment you got
to understand what's the expectation and
you got to go take it ain't nobody
giving you nothing no more you see how
it is when we drop something they enjoy
it they enjoy the Miss it's going to
take it because I like I like him to be
upset I like him to be angry I like him
to be mad so let's go take
it yeah basically telling us what we got
to do this week we got to go there take
a win nobody think we going to win the
game so we got to go then dominate come
with the win by any means no matter how
it is how pretty it is we just gotta go
down win it's time for uh
overaction and not overreaction so let's
get right into it first clip we got is
Keon Coman there a cheat
code Jord Travis got that ball in
there not about Keon about Travis
getting that ball in there look at
that only his receiver can cash
that yeah that's not over reaction
though reaction he definitely is Chico
he having out the nose go crazy right
now what we got next
that's overreaction that is not a
way that is definitely not the way a
coacher
dress no
sir a
v-neck cut off v-neck it's
crazy you deserve more credit n the
quarterback deserve more credit he
stayed poised he played
good that's over reaction not Utah the
quarterb back the quarterback came in
and Bal
out and the quarterback came in the ball
out bro needs to be a
linebacker 69 232 ain't no 69ine
linebacker he need to be a receiver or
something not no linebacker or
DN over reaction not no not no
linebacker a never seen no 69ine
linebacker 232
though ripping clothes to tacle should
be
legal working on
it not over reaction bro you gota
sometimes you got to grab whatever you
can grab to get them
down
that shouldn't be
[Music]
illegal sometimes you just got to grb
what you can grb man that's all it
is 5 yard penalty still First St Defense
number six 15yd penalty the result first
down face mask defense that penalty be
assessed on the kickoff the extra point
is good still first ey 10 y penalty
from first replay first
down he just talk funny that's all it
[Music]
is that five's widened out there Butch
why didn't you say that LOL isn't that
fun
go score come to score
score touchdown
Miami
caller oh thanks buddy got to stay
hydrated yo yo yo yo yo hey sir wait for
it time
out I'm fighting myself and myself is
winning he just goofy the charges fan
n that's our fans is man that's not
overreaction I mean over
reaction Char the charger fans was too
much no she's not she having fun at the
game she probably it's probably her
first time on the game she probably a
big
fan not be AC and by the way the chat
y'all lost Cowboys won they beat the
Chargers y'all voted on the cowbo I mean
the Chargers one all right y'all the
Olympics announced flag football as a
new sport in 2028 it's a long time from
now but yeah I'm going to build the best
possible offense and best possible
defense the USA for the
USA when we take the field in a few
years uh who's a good running back right
now all right
quarterback
Patrick Mahomes it's got to be Patrick
Mahomes running
back be on Robinson he can catch the
back field he
fast
receiver tarq Hill Target K as number
one
receiver
me me as the next receiver just pick me
for receiver
me
uh tight end definitely gotta be Travis
Kelce It's gotta be Travis Kel right
right WR right right he said Travis c g
be
50 wa 28 how old is Travis Kelsey right
now might have to pick a different type
he's 34 yeah he's not going to be the
elite any well he might be it's only a
good five years that
nah yeah we goingon to go with a
different tight uh who's a good tight
end oh Cal piix we could pick Cal P yeah
can I put that tight a rusher who could
put that a good
like that could be a good rusher we
could pick Parsons we could pick Parsons
right there for
rusher Parsons we could P him right
there for russer
DB Jaylen
Ramsey Ramsey
Patrick Satan yeah
Pat who else though safety safety safety
safety safety safety
safety put me at safety we got patri and
10 we got me at safety because I can
play both
[Music]
ways and flat football S I mean flat
football safety is easy I definitely
play
safety uh Minka first first PR F Patrick
how how you say his name fatrick yeah m
m that team gonna be unstoppable bro we
got straight ball Hawks on our team it's
gonna be crazy we got T little fast they
got me jump over everybody catch the
ball got Patrick Mahomes at quarterback
know he throwing dots me that running
back you know he fast he get out of B
field and catch the ball C picks yeah J
Michael Parsons yeah P
turn M yeah we lit we lit we lit we
lit all right next up we got a
blur let's get right into
it
[Music]
BL that's definitely a blur
no way he caught that that's
tough next I receiv tough that H
too blur everybody catching one hand
blurs
[Music]
d
That's give me
that
he should if it kept his feet he
probably would have scored on his head
on his head good
catch head top head top next we got
something called it's a new game it's
called what's next so basically you
gonna pause it before it get to the
final result and then I just gotta guess
it pretty much I gotta guess what
happened so let's get right into
that wait what is
this what is this pit pit wins the
gamees be
sure it's definitely
b f storm the field and Tack QB no it's
B for sure it's definitely
B QB all short like I said I knew
it I just knew
it he's definitely gonna get C short why
did you
slide for
what it made no sense to
slide oh I seen this place so this don't
even
count yep
hey it's definitely a he called fair
catch which he was waving his left left
arm which I don't get cuz when it tell
the call for a catch it's got to be high
but yeah he scored on
this got called
back they say he called for a catch with
his left hand watch his left hand they
say that's giving yourself up pretty
much it says to say your catch up here
and not down here so I don't even know
how they call that but they still C
that oh he was and bounce
too what happened
next it's definitely
C is C I say C I don't know I guess
see
see no he threw it out of Bounce
oh no wa threw the ball out of bounds
yeah that play was never going to work
anyway he blew it
up uh
uh C nah I want to say B I'm G say C
though I'm G say C I'm G say
C I knew it I just knew it I knew he was
gonna throw it I knew he was gonna throw
it I just knew he was gonna throw it
because most people thinking receiver G
oh yeah he F run he F tuck it and run he
threw it the
dot hey he zipped that thing that jum
was
perfect that was a freaking dot boy
ain't no way he do that dot like that
all right y'all before we get out of
here you know this week we gotta play
UCLA at UCLA gotta go in there get a dub
we gotta get back on
track uh we know we didn't have a good
we didn't have a good B week we know we
messed up uh two Fridays ago
we still got on our M we know we got to
go in there and work got to go back and
grind time to put a statement out there
let them know we still here go down win
come off fast finish
Fast uh it's time to put it put together
a good game fast game great game make
sure the fans know that we're here not
to play we're here to win and we're
gonna do it in a great fashion we G
right there ball out come out fast start
fast be disciplined knock those
penalties out the way we have too many
penalties right
now uh play good defense that's our main
thing we got to play good defense and
offense you know they take care of the
stuff offense go out there and do their
thing put up put some points on the
board so yeah gotta go out there just
dominate for me just go out there I
already knocked the rust off of me so
I'm good
now uh yeah go right there ball out
that's what we got to do appreciate
y'all it's your host Travis Hunter with
12 talks Bleacher Report thank y'all for
staying tuned and we out till next
Monday see
[Music]
you